regardez votre passé émission de télé
réalité et on va vous montrer le
meilleur ou le pire c'est selon c'est
une langue que font les marseillais w9
quand l'émission se termine ils ont
trois choix soit et tourner une nouvelle
télé-réalité dérivé de la première comme
on l'a vu hier pour carla et kevin qui
filment leur bébé soit malheureusement
ils vont pointer au pôle emploi ou soit
pire encore il intègre la télé réalité
de notre ami magali berna j'adore un
gars niche mais à l'agencé une
téléréalité qui s'appelle l'émission max
tape l'incrusté est diffusée sur la
chaîne non-stop réalité alors dans cet
épisode
magali enfin à refaire un tour dans le
dressing de maeva des marseille et comme
à son habitude maeva à son vocabulaire
bien à elle alors soit elle fabrique des
mots refusée par le dictionnaire
soit on a su que les gens avec de la
nourriture est bien là à la mixer les
deux c'est très fort regardez bien des
déchets les attentes à 20 ans je suis
d'accord mais il faut pouvoir pas sué
pour touba oui moi je suis et s'est
retranché nationale guirado
pour moi c'est un tournedos de l'appétit
et bien sûr c'est ça alors magali elle
continue à se promener chez maeva
structure du propriétaire
elle donne même son avis sur la déco
alors mag a laissé tout faire elle sait
lire écrire compter
le seul truc qui n'a pas encore appris
c'est les couleurs connais pas les
couleurs regarder ce que tu me fais
visiter bernuy voir ça c'est aussi aller
regarder vous devez entrer voilà on est
que toutes les deux mais c'est très rose
squatte le haut
voilà c'est très bleus avant cet eros
d'abord et on a changé de catégorie
[Applaudissements]
alors comme magali elle connaît bien
tous les marciel pas se faire un petit
coucou notre ami paga dans sa boutique
de fringues et pour faire une bonne
séquence magali à l'idée d'un petit jeu
elle demande à paga de se déguiser pour
ne pas être reconnus par les clips alors
là c'est et costis aulas je me suis ici
c'est que cette histoire et c'est
curieux mais visiblement n'a gagné
magali donc s'étonne elle même de
comprendre de comprendre les règles de
son propre jeu regardez-moi ça aussi
c'est un petit moment coup ci en plus
j'étais pris un masque regardez jean
d'halloween zine ben ali
exactement ça te plaît au parc portuaire
mais je suis sûr que au milieu de sa
mère à côté dieu
[Applaudissements]
on adore ça y est je suis fan
alors on laisse magali bernard regarder
les dora l'exploratrice et on retourne
voir du côté des marseillais si tout va
bien sur w9 alors serge coupe comme
c'est un programme familial
w9 aurait demandé aux candidats des
marseillais de jouer la carte de la
sobriété notamment sur les tenues
sachez qu'il y en a une qui a reçu le
message cinq sur cinq
c'est manon elle s'habille très très
soft comme celle aller faire les courses
chez picard regarde c'est trop loin
c'est pas trop buggé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pouvez-vous dire non
de toutes parts et à toi c'est une
souris et sfr le marché cette partie
quoi sans école et ses manières
alors pour ceux qui ne remettent pas
bien je vous présente et n'a qu'à et là
alors c'est une erreur alors si vous ne
connaissez pas bien c'est assez rare
pour être souligné menaka à des choses
très importantes à dire un milliard
alors comme ils sont dans une boîte de
nuit c'est pas forcément le bon endroit
pour se livrer à corps ouverts bien
entendu alors comme naka il est très
rapide dans sa tête il a dit des de
l'emmener dans un endroit beaucoup plus
tranquille beaucoup plus romantique
laquelle beaucoup plus relax on est là
je dis chapeau l'artiste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jerry et enfin pour le plaisir dans les
génies du pavot outre un joli moment
dans bienvenue chez nous sur tf1 quand
les enfants parlent de leur papa c'est
très émouvant
vous allez voir et quand les enfants
parlent de leur maman c'est moins
glamour
je crois que benjamin castaldi va vite
tomber amoureux de cette jeune femme
après cette image peut compter sur le
sensible enzo pour apporter un peu de
douceur
mon parcours et les antilles et camping
et easy il ne compte pas longtemps que
ma maman c'est madame piteuse elle fait
que péter
[Applaudissements]